you did a good job I thought when Julie
left the show I saw you right before
that you like we don't know what's gonna
happen yeah and and then she did wind up
yeah really how come she didn't actually
come on the show with you guys I have no
idea we didn't speak we I haven't spoken
to Julian forever we didn't speak during
the break or she didn't call and say I'm
having to go that tape was delivered and
that was it oh yeah so there was no was
it tense so were you guys oh no oh yeah
we were we were because we were going
back and forth and thinking you know
she's sticking by her husband and the
things that we discuss on the show it
would be so awkward for her I don't know
how she could come into a conversation
and give an opinion that wasn't well you
know if she thinks her husband wasn't
guilty but this one's guilty you know
what I'm saying
it would have been terribly embarrassing
for her I think she's humiliating
especially since he was everybody's boss
that's just a tough just really really
tough on her I mean you know when they
were doing the investigation I think
that every female employee through CBS
got a letter from the people that are
doing the investigation for the company
to say have you ever had any
inappropriate meetings with him has he
ever been inappropriate with you and
then you've got to go in there and say
every day and look and and to you know
when your husband has been the boss and
he's run everything and when you come in
everybody is doing an invisible curtsy
milady milady and then you come in and
if you want a cappuccino oh actually you
have to pay for that now right I mean
you can't go back to being a an employee
right because it wasn't like she was an
employee she was I knew yeah Julie
didn't reach out to you but did any of
you guys reach out to Julie to see how
she was doing
I can't I don't know for the other
ladies I don't know